rescued from the Reich is the story of
rabbi joseph shnayerson head of the
Hasidic Lubavitch er movement who
escaped to America in 1940 this talk is
an hour and a half thank you very much
Thank You director Strauss and director
Ryan's for having me again can everybody
hear me okay now can everybody hear me
okay I'm going to wait we have we are
blessed to have c-span here tonight I'm
just going to wait in here if they are
okay okay well good evening ladies and
gentlemen and thank you very much for
coming tonight
I am honored to have in the audience my
wonderful and law's mary-dell and dr.
Paul Stelter and also we're honored in
the audience to have a Miss know mark
our new mark she is the daughter of
Samuel Kramer and Debby Newmarket joins
us here and Samuel Kramer was very
instrumental in organizing this rescue
without this gentleman the rubbish
nursing would not have gotten out of
Europe during World War two now before I
begin I'd like to give you a little
background on my person I was born in
Texas in 1971 and I was raised in a very
Protestant environment I did not know
about my own Jewish background until I
was 21 when I went over to Germany and
started researching my family's past and
I found all these Jews in the family
tree and I did not know what that meant
at that time I just had visions of an
old white guy coming off a mountain with
two rocks in his hands I had no con
context from which to put that
information into and understand about my
Jewish background and so when I came
back to Yale University to begin my
sophomore year in 1992 I began talking
to a lot of my Jewish friends about what
it meant to be Jewish and who was a Jew
and I was at the Hillel there and during
the course of this conversation a
Orthodox rabbi in the corner of the room
overheard it came over and
I started mapping out my family's tree
and suddenly he got very excited and he
said Baruch Hashem you're a Jew and I
asked him well what does that mean he
says well according to halakha Jewish
law you are a Jewish welcome to the
tribe and soon thereafter I got a book
by Donnan called to be a Jew from him
and then about a year later I got a
scholarship from him to go to our Samia
ku Shiva and Jerusalem and study with
the yeshiva bulk was there in Sheva boys
and so I really embraced my Jewish
background and I'm proud of that legacy
when I was in the Marine Corps actually
I was in a platoon and that had a man by
the name of Schweitzer had another guy
by the name of leaves from you know the
tribe of Lebon and then there was rig me
and I was the only person that knew the
Shema yeah and every night before we
went to bed we would line up and in the
Marine Corps I would always say God
country and Kor put our heads down put
our hands together and there would be
somebody that would lead us in a
Protestant prayer and then a Catholic
prayer and I went up to the company
commander I said hey we got three people
here in the platoon better of Jewish
descent do you mind if I do the Shema
every night and he agreed to do so so
every night I led the Shema for
Schweitzer Lee and myself I also got the
other extreme of Jewish experience and
did a little stint in the Israeli
military in 1998 so I've embraced that
and the reason why I tell you about that
is had I not found out about my own
Jewish background I would not be
standing before you talking to you about
a book about Nazi Germany in the Third
Reich I also like to give you a little
background on my educational history I
have the dubious honour of having failed
first grade twice I have I have why
people today call ADHD or attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder I uh back
when I was a kid it was called hld
hyperkinesis learning disabled or MBD
minimal brain dysfunction I also had a
speech impediment when I was
kid I got my teas and F's mixed up all
the time so when I played with my trucks
around my family's friends it was quite
interesting conversation are when I
asked the babysitter to tuck me into bed
my mom was beside herself with grief
going over a yeah what am I going to do
with this kid so after I filled first
grade twice and sort of having these
creative language skills my mom realized
she had to do as she had to do something
very quickly she had this nightmare that
her 20 year old son would be able to
eventually drive himself to his own
sixth grade graduation if she didn't do
something so she started looking around
the area in dallas-fort worth where we
lived to find a special school for me
and she found one at Texas Christian
University called star point and it was
a lab school that focused on severely
learning disabled children
I met all the requirements was accepted
and when I went there I was very
demoralized since the school that I had
gone to where I felt first grade at
twice was also the church that my family
went to every Wednesday night every
Sunday morning and every Sunday night I
was continually reminded of my failures
so when I went to the school I was very
down on my luck and I told Mary Stewart
my teacher about this and after she
heard about my experiences she said
Brian you're not a freak you're not
abnormal you're just different you're
not learning disabled you're learning
different and I'm here to help you find
your strength and in one year I went
from not being able to pronounce
individual words to reading books at the
third fourth and fifth grade level and
doing math at the junior high level
I also thank God figured out the
difference between T's and FS and she
taught me through this experience she
said look Brian you're contrarian all
those kids were calling you stupid that
you couldn't read and now you're reading
at a higher level than they are she also
taught me through this experience that
when people label criticism at you
they're telling you more about
themselves than they are about who you
really are
and that philosophy has really lived
with me for
the rest of my life and when I graduated
Yale University with honors in history
that teacher Mary Stewart was there
she's been a guiding light an angel in
my life and I tell you that because
without that experience I would not be
in front of you you know today also I
had wonderful mother and grandmother
that helped me with my learning
disabilities and they got me on
all-natural diet the Feingold diet that
really helped me they took away
artificial flavors and artificial colors
and that got me on track as well and I'm
still on this diet today and watch what
I eat
a lot of people don't realize that
artificial flavors and artificial colors
and preservatives they're
petroleum-based products you're actually
eating oil when you eat them BHT which
is in a lot of cereal that's actually
formaldehyde that's what they used in
bombed bodies with so when I would eat
that with the sensitive system that I
had would make me go haywire so I tell
you this information again to give you a
little background on my person and also
let you understand that when I started
researching about a Nazi soldier
rescuing the head of Lubavitch the most
Orthodox rabbi in 1939 out of Europe and
most of my professors told me hey you're
not going to find anything that contrary
and kicked in and said hey I'll look
look into it and see what I find so now
to my research in 1992 I began
researching the phenomenon about Jews
and men of Jewish descent who served in
the German armed forces during World War
two the results of which were published
in 2002 as Hitler's Jewish soldiers
during the course of this research I
came across the story about our
anti-semitic anti-refugee US government
working with the Nazi Secret Service to
rescue a rabbi and what makes the story
even more incredible is that the person
that the German secret service used to
rescue the rabbi was a half Jewish
German major who have been Arian eyes by
Hitler now ladies and gentlemen tonight
I'll be using terms like half Jew
quarter Jew Aryan please have these
terms in quotation marks in your mind's
eyes they are Nazi terms but they help
us understand the history from back then
and when I first came across this story
as one can well imagine
I doubted the validity of it but further
research has proved the truth of it and
it has been a wild journey that has
brought me in touch with some some
wonderful professors and historians of
the Third Reich like Jonathan Steinberg
Michael Berra Bell David Krantz ler and
Henry Feingold it also has brought me in
touch with several Valmont veterans of
Jewish descent Valmont is the German
term for the Armed Forces of World War
two and it's brought me in touch with
numerous rabbis at one of the most
ultra-orthodox Jewish sects the Labov
atures now some of you might be asking
if this you know this story is so
incredible why hasn't it been documented
until now
well the lab AMA tours are very a
historical group they look at this in a
very spiritual very spiritual way and
many of them have not looked into it in
depth also the documents are spread out
all over the world and so many of them
have just you know carried on the oral
tradition that God saved the Rebbe and
that's basically the explanation that
was good enough for them also some
historians and journalists have touched
upon this rescue but usually only in a
few pages are a few paragraphs to the
best of my knowledge this is the first
historical account to synthesize sources
from the lavalla Jers documents from the
archives National Archives in America as
well as Germany and written in oral
testimonies into a single book much of
what I'm about to tell you has never
been told before and in order to write
this book I had to go over 10,000 pages
of documents read over 60 books of the
secondary literature interview over 60
interview individuals and collect
hundreds of photographs
now in order for you to understand this
rescue you must have a fundamental
understanding of the Labov atures and
their arch leader
the Rebbe the ultra-orthodox Jewish sect
known as the lab altars had its origins
in the Hasidic movement which began
around 1730 under the charismatic
leadership of the Baal Shem Tov Hasidic
is the Hebrew word for pious now the
Baal Shem Tov came on the scene when
German I mean when Eastern European
Jewry was suffering a lot of hardships
they had undergone the trauma of the
false crusade of Sabbath I see the false
messiah crusade of sabotage fee in 1666
and they have been devastated by pogroms
in Poland and Russia so they were hung
hungry for a better future and for a
better way to connect with God and the
baal shem tov tapped into their desires
with amazing power and by the end of his
life in 1760 the Hasidic movement
numbered and to the hundreds of
thousands
this Hasidic movement is somewhat akin
to what happened here in America with
the Great Awakening of what the baal
shem tov was able to do for Eastern
European Jewry now soon after his death
several of his closest disciples spread
out through Eastern Europe and they set
up their own schools of theology and
their own Hasidic sects one of them was
Rebbe schnur's almond of lydia who set
up his headquarters in Lubavitch russia
hence the term the Lubov atures now the
Lubov occurs believe that like other
Hasidic sects that their Rebbe and their
philosophy their Chabad philosophy were
incomparable Chabad is an acronym for
the Hebrew words Hoch mabini and dot
meaning wisdom understanding and
knowledge and these are Kabbalistic
terms or Jewish mystical terms and the
Labov atures believe that every Jew
should have a deep and mystical
connection with God and have a thorough
understanding of the 613 commandments
that God has given every Jew to fulfill
in his or her life and although messy
ISM has been a constant theme of Judaism
the last 2,000 years the laboratories
focus much more on the Messiah and
each Jew must do to hasten his arrival
than other Hasidic sects and this has
caused some controversy recently when
Menachem Mendel Schneerson the seventh
Lubavitch Rebbe passed away with no heir
apparent and many in the community
declared that he was indeed the mashiac
of the Messiah also since the beginning
of this group each Rebbe has focused
heavily on outreach programs building up
Chabad houses all over the world as they
call them as many of you know who have
had contact with Labov ik there's not a
corner on this world without al abama
chur Chabad house I saw a cartoon
recently that illustrates that point
dramatically it shows a picture of Mars
as you as and as you look at this
cartoon it says underneath intelligent
life has been found on the Red Planet
and as you look over the horizon you see
the golden rings and McDonald's and then
next to it you see a kebab house so they
have really been amazing with their
outreach program now I've used the term
Rebbe several times and many people have
asked me about this word the term Rebbe
is a variation of the word rabbi which
means my teacher or my leader and is the
title given to heads of Hasidic courts
while there can be many rabbis in one
Hasidic community there usually can be
only one Rebbe somewhat akin to the
Catholic community where you can have
one pope but many priests and in the
Hasidic community the leadership of a
Rebbe is usually dynastic now the low
bow voters believe that their Rebbe
are endowed with mystical powers and are
the potential messiahs of their
generations now for most observant Jews
every generation has a potential Messiah
the llevaba true just believe that if
the Messiah is going to come it's going
to indeed be their Rebbe they also
believe that the Rebbe is endowed with
myth with them the Holy Spirit the raw
Kadesh and is without sin elie wiesel a
noted holocaust writer and survivor and
Nobel Peace Prize winner eloquently
eloquently describes what these revaz
are he says he is what can
what man wants to be he is the chosen
one who is denied nothing in heaven on
earth God is angry he can make him smile
God is severe he can induce him to
leniency the labatto's also believe that
their Rebbe zan electorally know and
emotionally feel the spiritual and
physical needs of every Jew everywhere
and know how to connect him or her to
God and reveal his or her role in the
divine blueprint of humanity so for
members of Chabad they believe that
their Rebs are not only perfect human
beings but prophetic figures worthy of
total submission Elie Wiesel goes on to
explain that in Hassidim the Rebbe by
the virtue of the strength he incarnates
and the majesty he invokes is the father
figure par excellence
someone good yet strict someone
charitable yet severe tolerant with
others but inflexible with himself in
other words a singular human being and
whom all attributes converge and whom
all contradictions are resolved the
labatto's also believe that their Rebbe
s once dead unlike other Jews who have
died are closer to heaven to God and are
still able to hear the requests of
people down here on earth and as a
result many labatto's go to the grave
sites of their revs and leave prayer
requests there so that they may be heard
more quickly
when our story starts unfold in the
1930s six generation of Schneerson
family members had led the movement of
Lubavitch as Rev E's and the current
leader was the six lubavitcher rebbe
Joseph is sock Schneerson who was born
in 1880 in Lubavitch Russia and assumed
command of the leadership in 1920 on the
death of his father he came on the scene
as leader of lahbab ik when Russian jury
was having a lot of difficulties mostly
vouchers at this time we're living in
Russia and since the Soviet Union had
taken over power they had outlawed a lot
of religious organizations and religious
education and this is one of the core
tenets of Lubavitch and low Babak mostly
vouchers are very stubborn and they
refused to obey these decrees and as a
result many of them were arrested and
sent off to gulags in siberia and killed
the Rebbe himself was arrested several
times beaten up horribly in jail and in
1927 he was condemned to death but
before the death sentence was carried
out several prominent individuals
throughout the world one of them being
Leo Beck rabbi famous Reform rabbi in
Germany Leo Beck and even our president
in the United States President Coolidge
wrote on his behalf
under this pressure the Rebbe was
released but the Soviet Union was tired
of the Rebbe shenanigans and they kicked
him out of the country and he went to
Riga Latvia where he became a Latvian
citizen but then soon thereafter he
moved down to Warsaw Poland where he set
up his headquarters outside of the
capital and a town called out Vaux now
by 1939 his new headquarters there had
spread out his tentacles all throughout
the world in America at this time
according to lebarge sources there was
around 150,000 Lobo atures here and also
this headquarters was doing a lot of
work clandestinely of course to support
communities in Russia in 1939 the Rebbe
was 59 years old and he was not in very
good health probably due to all the
persecution he had suffered under under
the Soviets he had suffered a heart
attack and a stroke and he was sick with
multiple sclerosis a degenerative
disease of the central nervous system
symptoms of which range from paralysis
numbness to incontinence all of us
rebby seem to suffer from he also had
difficulty moving around he had to be
put in a wheelchair to go from one point
to another and he also had to be helped
up from chairs and out from cars he also
had difficulty speaking when he did
speak it sounded like he was mumbling
and his volume was not very high also
adding to his ill health was the fact
that he was overweight and he smoked
over a pack of cigarettes a day there
wasn't a lot of knowledge back then
about the dangers of smoking standing at
5 foot 8 and weighing over 200 pounds he
didn't strike a very impressive figure
physically yet his followers thought of
him as an incredible spiritual giant our
story begins on the 1st of September
1939 when Germany invaded Poland and has
1.5 million German troops crossed over
the border into Poland 3.3 million Jews
lived in that nation by 1945 only a few
hundred thousand of those Jews had
survived the Shoah had survived the
Holocaust with this in mind one sees
that half of the 6 million Jews who died
in the Holocaust were Polish Jews
Hitler's blitzkrieg tactics quickly
overwhelmed the Polish nation preventing
most Jews from escaping behind his
military legions came his killing squads
that quickly implemented his worldview
of doing away with undesirables like
socialists priests members of the
Intelligencia and Jews many of these
barbaric acts were done in front of Alma
commanders who surprisingly decided to
protest these acts one of them was the
head of the German secret service the
abbe there admiral wilhelm canaris and
he believed that these atrocities defame
the german nation and that these units
should be removed from Poland at once
now when these protests reached Hitler
Hitler declared that our struggle must
not be measured by terms of legality or
illegality our methods must conform to
our principles we must prevent a new
Polish intelligentsia from seizing power
and rid the greater German Reich of
Polish
Jewish riffraff was such a policy in
place the Jews of Poland quickly fell
into the abyss of the Holocaust Jews who
would survive in Poland during World War
two
did so by passing themselves off as
Aryans as the Nazis would call them
serving with the partisans are surviving
the ghettos and death camps and one of
the most remarkable rescues are escapes
if you will from Nazi Germany and Nazi
occupied Europe in World War two was the
escape of Joseph azox nursin head of
lahbab ik and he did so with the help of
add their agents with the help of German
Secret Service agents
now as I studied this story the more I
came to really believe that truth is
indeed stranger than fiction and to set
that tone I like to tell you the
following story a little boy comes home
from Hebrew school and his mother asked
him hey Johnny what did you learn today
Johnny says you know mom I really don't
want to talk about it she's like no
Johnny I'd be interested come on tell me
hon what did you learn it's like well
mom we we learned about this guy by the
name of Moses and he was in Egypt at the
time he was tired away tired of the way
the Egyptians were treating the Jews so
he gathered all the Jews together there
was a few million of a mom and he
escaped from Egypt and then they came up
to the Red Sea and suddenly they heard
that the Egyptian army was coming after
them mom I'm going to kill him so Moses
he he got on his walkie-talkie and he
called in the Israeli Air Force the bomb
and strafe the Egyptians and while the
Air Force mom was bombing and strafing
the Egyptians he had his pioneers build
this huge pontoon bridge across the Red
Sea and then he got the millions and
millions of Israelites across that
pontoon bridge across the Red Sea on the
other side and then mommy put satchel
charges all along that bridge and then
when the Egyptians came on that bridge
he had those satchel charges blown up
the Egyptians mom they can't swim so
when they fell in the water they all
drowned and that's why we have the State
of Israel today the mom looks down at
Johnny says Johnny is that what you
really learned in Hebrew school today
Johnny looked down at the ground kind of
shuffled his feet he says no mom but if
I told you the truth you wouldn't
believe it
now when the Germans invaded Poland
many of the Labov atures there went up
to the Rebbe and they said Rebbe you got
to get out of here it's dangerous to
stay the Germans are going to come here
but the Rebbe did not agree with the
timing or methods he said that the Lord
Almighty would take care of his children
and times of danger and that he is a
shepherd of his flock should not leave
them and times of misfortune
he also said slamming his cane down on
the ground that he would not have to get
out of Poland but Hitler would have to
leave yet for all of his bravado he soon
saw the writing on the wall and he
realized that he indeed needed to get
out of Poland and the plan was to take a
car from a fox to Warsaw and then once
in Warsaw to get on a train there and
get to Riga Latvia
to freedom and before he left all his
followers who had to remain behind he
told them be well and accept the yoke of
heaven upon yourselves remember that the
king takes care of those who serve Him
remember also that you are children of
God and may he protect you and keep you
alive may he watch over all of us and
let us survive and with that he got into
the car and started on his way to Warsaw
now the road leading to the capital was
lying with the dead remains of horses
civilians and Polish soldiers all caught
in the maelstrom of battle all along the
horizon you saw the crumpled heaps of
villages and buildings that have been
hit by the Luftwaffe the German air
force in large black plumes of smoke
rose up high into the air the sky in the
earth seemed to be welded together into
the chaos of war and as the Rebbe and
many of his followers were driving
through this horror many then became
scared for their lives and they started
yelling out the Shema the holy jewish
prayer they thought that they were about
to meet their maker but the Rebbe calmed
them down telling them that God was
watching after them and that his father
v Lubavitch Rebbe was right then and
there in heaven interceding on their be
has with God a journey that should have
taken them only a few you know half an
hour too
our took them several hours but
eventually they arrived in Warsaw
but the Rebbe wasn't able to escape the
main train station had been bombed down
to the ground and most of the Train
links leading down to the capital have
been destroyed by the Luftwaffe so the
Rebbe was trapped and here is a picture
of Warsaw in 1939 during the bombing
campaign 40% of the city would be bombed
down to the ground and over 40,000
civilians would lose their lives so the
Rebbe was in the middle of a war zone
but he seemed to be always followed by a
divine cloud of protection one time he
left a building in a minute later it was
hit by bombs from the Luftwaffe the
whole structure came crumbling down
everybody died another time he was in a
courtyard during a bombing attack
everybody outside that courtyard was hit
and killed the Rebbe was thrown by the
concussion from one side to the other
side yet he was untouched another time
the Rebbe was studying his Torah at a
desk in somebody's home during a bombing
attack and the whole place was sprayed
with shrapnel yet the Rebbe and his
Torah run touched many people at this
time felt that if they wanted to survive
the Nazi bombardment of Warsaw they just
had to stay close to the Rebbe now the
Rebbe during this time since he couldn't
leave he was trying to get a lot of his
yeshiva students out on foot to neutral
countries he also was doing everything
he could to save his library he had a
deep and mystical attachment to his
forty thousand book library on the 17th
of September and also I'm going to have
the this scene in your mind's eye during
bombing attacks the Rebbe was in a
wheelchair so during a bombing attack
his yeshiva students had to run up to
his room pick him up in the wheelchair
carry him downstairs and into a bunker a
bunker if the building got destroyed
they had to put him on a stretcher or
put him in the wheelchair and carry him
through the burning streets of Warsaw so
this is what's going on all during this
time 17th of September the low boxer has
got a lot of bad news the Soviet Union
had invaded Poland from the east and
we're moving quickly on to the capital
and the Lavaca church felt that if the
Rebbe fell into the hands of the Soviets
no amount of international
sure would help save him this time yet
they also felt the coils of the Nazi
regime tightening around the capital and
they knew that if the Nazis got their
hands on the Rebbe he would also be
murdered on the 25th of September Hitler
decided to raise the whole capital to
the ground he was tired of the
intransigence of the Polish High
commands and willingness to surrender
and so he had all his forces focused on
the capital 500 tons of explosives and
72 tons of incinerators were dropped on
the city by the low fafa accompanied by
hundreds of tons of artillery shells the
whole place erupted into an inferno yet
once again the Rebbe survived and on the
27th of September the Polish High
Command finally surrendered
now the Rebbe was under control the
Nazis and many at this time felt that he
would soon be killed and they were you
know struck with grief they felt that
the greatest Jewish sage and even the
potential Messiah of their generation
was going to be taken from them during
this time many laboratories in America
we're doing everything they could to get
a rescue plan organized and the Rebbe
had had the good fortune in 1930 to have
met President Herbert Hoover justice
Louis Brandeis and Senator Robert Wagner
during a goodwill tour here in the
United States so the vouchers in America
this time naturally contacted these men
to try to get a rescue plan organized
into their great luck into their great
surprise
these men decided to act on it and they
sent the request of the chain of command
and this eventually arrived at the desk
of Secretary of State Cordell Hull and
assistant attorney general Benjamin
Cohen the architect of the New Deal and
these men must have got the approval
from Roosevelt because a few days later
the State Department as you see with
this telegram here up on the PowerPoint
screen the State Department sent a
telegram to the American Embassy in
Berlin for them to find the Rebbe and
rescue him as you see in the right hand
corner you'll see the signature of hole
he sanctioned this document soon
thereafter the State Department was able
to establish contact with the head of
the German secret service Admiral
Wilhelm Canaris
who
decided to actually help us Canaris is a
strange bird on one side he gave the van
Mach invaluable military intelligence to
conduct its operations during the war he
agreed with doing away with communism
and he also wanted to get back a lot of
the lands that were taken from Germany
with the Versailles Treaty yet on the
other side he did not agree with a lot
of the Nazi government's policies
against racial inferiors as they were
described and he approved this by
helping several Jews escape Germany
throughout the 1930s and also hiring
several people of Jewish descent in his
own organization so from an ideological
point of view Canaris was a good ally to
have also remember ladies and gentlemen
in 1939 Germany was not at war with
America and canaras wanted to keep it
that way so he wanted to keep a certain
modicum of goodwill between the two
nations so he could not ignore a request
from some of the highest levels of the
US government so we decided to act on
this and canaras ordered one of his most
trusted officers major Ernst Bloch to
lead the mission on the ground this
gentleman had no relationship to the
famous composer or philosopher Ernst
Bloch that is that I know of Ernst Bloch
was a creature of war in 1914 at the
outbreak of World War one he volunteered
for military service at the age of 16 in
1915 during hand-to-hand combat he
suffered a horrible wound to his face
taking a bayonet up through his jaw his
mouth and into his brain dividing his
face vertically he was left for dead on
the battlefield and three days later as
they were bulldozing a whole bunch of
dead bodies into a mass grave one of
them screamed out it was blocked and
after 20 surgeries to his face in about
four months of convalescent leave he
returned to the murders trenches of the
Western Front and served three more
years as an infantry officer taking 8
more wounds taking shrapnel to his head
his torso his arms and bullet wounds to
one
Legg he into the war as a first
lieutenant and decorated with the
equivalent of nine Purple Hearts two
Bronze Stars and two silver stars this
guy was a true warrior and he was also a
true survivor after World War one he
made the successful transition into the
Reichswehr the military under the vimar
republic in 1924 he got his doctorate in
economics in 1933 he made the successful
transition into the army of the Third
Reich and in 1935
Canaris hired him to be head of the
economic Espionage division of the abbé
there yet there was one problem Ernst
Bloch was a half Jew so canaras had to
get an application together with Bloch
and submitted to Hitler to get block
aryan eyes in Hitler's warped view of
genetics he really believed that if a
half Jew or a quarter Jew had blond hair
blue eyes and a good military track
record that he was being dominated by
his Aryan blood and as a result Hitler
reserved the right to give such people
the kosher stamp of approval of Aryan
hood if you will and Blanc receives such
an absurd award but Bloch was not unique
generals Admirals u-boat captains
battleship captain's fighter aces
Divisional Commanders and thousands of
ordinary so-called Michelin soldiers as
the Nazis called them half Jewish and
quarter Jewish soldiers all served
because Hitler allowed them too many of
them with a personal exemption from him
and this is written up in detail in my
first book Hitler's Jewish soldiers so
Bloch was not unique having this
exemption he was not he was also not
unique being a half Jew in the military
I conservatively estimate that 60,000
half Jews and 90,000 quarter Jews served
in the German armed forces during World
War two and this is also written up in
my first book so Blanc is not unique
being a half Jew in the military and
having an exemption from Hitler but he
was unique for this rescue mission
Canaris obviously picked block because
of blocks own Jewish background but he
also picked block because block was
extremely intelligent very professional
had a lot of international
Travel experience and spoke three
foreign languages so block was sent off
to Warsaw and to rescue the Rebbe now
imagine this scene if you will Canaris
orders block into his office he sits him
down he says block I have an interesting
operation for you you're going to go up
to Warsaw you're going to find the most
ultra Orthodox rabbi in the world and
you're going to rescue him you can't
miss him he looks just like Moses and
then he sends them off to Warsaw to do
this and Blanc is going around door to
door and asking Orthodox Jews and Warsaw
about the Rebbe now now you know it took
a while for the information to get to
the lovers that this guy was indeed
there to help rescue him as many of you
will know with the La Batre community
that if you tell one la bocha Rebbe one
Lubavitch a rabbi something tonight ten
thousand of them will know it tomorrow
but in times of war this took a while
what Canaris did is he sent information
to washington DC about his this
operation this information got into the
hands of the lobbyists there and the the
linchpin the person that was really key
to this rescue Samuel Kramer which here
again we're honored to have his daughter
here Debbie Ninoy mark and once he got
this information he sent that
information on to the lab archers in
Brooklyn New York then once in Brooklyn
New York the lebackes were sent that
information onto the laboratories in
Riga Latvia and once that information
was there the lebara started sitting
runners down on the ground from Riga
Latvia to Warsaw to inform the Rebbe but
here again this was time consuming and
so block is having a lot of problems as
he's walking around Warsaw and here
again have this in your mind's eye he's
ever bit the hardened veteran his face
is vertically divided by this horrible
scar he has swastikas all over his
uniform iron crosses and he's going up
to ultra Hasidic Lubavitch or Jews with
three or four other officers and
soldiers and trail and he's asking them
hey
where's the Rebbe we want to rescue him
and the lebarge were saying yeah sure
you do and we want to join the German
army yeah where do we shave off our
beards and throw away our yarmulkes I
mean it was such an absurd situation but
eventually the Rebbe again Superman gets
information that block is indeed there
to rescue him and he hands himself over
and 20 of his closest family members and
disciples two blocks care now block is
faced with taking this group of
ultra-orthodox Jews through SS
checkpoints and many of these SS
checkpoints were very problematic for
block but one in particular is
noteworthy block comes up to this the
checkpoint an SS officer walks up to him
he's in his black uniform SS runes and
he's very skeptical of this situation of
this picture it's not the usual modus
operandi of an ab fair officer to
conduct you know a tour of Warsaw with
20 ultra-orthodox Jews and trail and
after block explains a little bit what
he's doing the SS officer says you know
I've got no verification from Berlin you
have not been able to convince me of
your mission and you know we should be
taking these Jews out and shooting them
not taking them around to trains and so
on a block gets very angry he starts
dropping names he starts that you know
Canaris head of the AB fair has sent me
here then he starts naming other
officers in the region who were in
charge of regiments and divisions
something the SS officer gets a little
nervous and wanting to protect his
backside he opens up the barricade and
Lex block through block gets back into
the truck with the Rebbe they drive on
and then block looks over to the reving
says don't worry about it I'm half
Jewish I'm here to help you meshuggah
and good hebrew crazy but nonetheless
true
and block is successful in getting
through all these SS checkpoints to a
train station outside of warsaw that was
still working now it was understandable
why the lobos's were so skeptical this
man at first because all during this
time Jews are being killed and this
picture unfortunately shows that they're
taken being taken out made to dig their
own graves and then shot in the back of
their heads so this is the dramatic
background that's going on at this time
as block is rescuing the Rebbe here's an
oversight
right of the map of Europe the yellow
portion of the map is what went to
Soviet Union after the conquest of
Poland and then the middle part the
greyish purple part is the section of
Poland that went to Germany and that's
where everything that we were talking
about today took place now here is the
next stage of the comedy blog gets them
to the train station outside of Warsaw
AB their agents quite often only
traveled in first class cabins in Nazi
Germany and Nazi Germany only fill grade
and general officers and high party
officials traveled in first class cabins
so Bloch enters this first class cabin
in this train with 20 ultra-orthodox
Jews with their captain's their fur has
their yarmulkes their tits it's coming
out of their a suits and the officers
Admirals and Generals they are very
confused by this what are you doing but
block once again uses his incredible
acting skills gets by these very
difficult situations and they get on the
train they take that train from outside
of Warsaw to Berlin and I think there's
two reasons why they went all the way
out of their way to Berlin instead of
going directly to the Lithuanian border
which was the plan in order to get ready
Schneerson to Riga Latvia the two
reasons I think they did this was the
first one is to throw off the scent of
the Gestapo and the second reason was
remember Rebbe Schneerson was still a
Latvian citizen
so when Bloch got him to Berlin he
handed the Rebbe and many of his family
members and disciples who were also
Latvian citizens over to the Latvian
diplomats to get their travel papers
once he was able to complete this they
then the next day left from Berlin and
they went to the border Lithuania and
that's where Bloch bid the Rebbe
farewell and as the Rebbe crossed over
the border into Lithuania hundreds of
labatto's were there singing and dancing
their leader had survived and had
escaped and then rubbish nursin went on
to Riga and waited for his visa from the
United States also during this time he
was doing everything he could to rescue
his library he had a deep and mystical
attachment to his books one could even
say he had an obsessive attachment to
these books and you did not want to
depart with them
he also was having many people in the
United States many of his leaders do
everything they could to work with the
government to get a lot of his personal
effects out his pots and pans and his
jewelry and home goods now it was very
difficult to get a visa at this time
this is a sad chapter in the United
States history we prevented hundreds of
thousands of people from coming to this
nation because our State Department was
motivated by anti-refugee and
anti-semitic sentiments and the sad
thing is ladies and gentlemen we
actually had visas for these people just
to give you a little indication about
the spirit that people were dealing with
in the State Department the following
story is quite telling the person that
was head of the immigration office was
Breckenridge long and he was a horrible
horrible individual and a person in his
organization was approached to help
rescue 20,000 beautiful innocent Jewish
children in Europe and we had the ships
we were sending a lot of ships over to
Europe at this time with supplies and
they were coming back empty we could
have put the kids on the ship well this
person in the Breckenridge langues
office said yes but 20,000 beautiful
Jewish children grow up to be 20,000
ugly Jewish adults and this was the type
of spirit that people were combating at
this time to get a visa but the Rebbe
was lucky he still had a lot of
prominent individuals pushing his case
and eventually he did get his visa and
in March of 1940 he took one of the last
planes from Riga to Stockholm Sweden and
the what makes this so remarkable is
that a few weeks later the Soviet Union
would take over most of the Baltics Toto
take over all the Baltic States and many
of the rabbi's who remained back there
were sent off to gulags and Siberia and
killed as anti revolutionaries so had
the Rebbe remained in Riga for a few
more weeks he most likely would have
been killed
now once the Rebbe was in Stockholm he
took a train and then to the town of
Gothenburg on the western coast once
there he bordered the ocean liner the
draughting home and took that ship
through the Baltic Sea along the western
coast of Norway and then
out to the Atlantic what makes this so
remarkable is that a few weeks later the
Nazi regime would invade Denmark and
Norway taking over those nations and
cutting off most of the shipping lanes
going in and out of the Baltic Sea in
preparation for this attack Germany had
sent 90% of its u-boat force off the
coast of Norway two ships that left
before the rebbe ship left were hit by
torpedoes sunk everybody died on board
two ships leaving after the rebbe ship
left were hit by torpedoes sunk
everybody died the rebbe when he got
around to Bergen had mechanical problems
the ship had mechanical problems and it
was a sitting duck there for a whole day
but luckily they got the engine repaired
and continued on its way you can just
imagine how the Rebbe is feeling at this
time finally on my way to freedom I'm
away from Nazi Germany and then all of a
sudden up from under the ocean comes
bubbling a German u-boat red flag
unfurled big black swastika and you can
just imagine what the people on board
are thinking because most of the people
on this ship or Jewish refugees yet
luckily the German u-boat captain was
not there to enforce Nazi racial policy
he was just there to see if there was
any military hardware on the ship and
once he was able to verify that there
was no military counter ban on the ship
he let it continue on its way but that
was not the end of the danger Germany
had laid thousands and thousands of
mines all in the North Sea in the
northern Atlantic around Scotland and
all around Great Britain a ship that was
one day's journey ahead of the rebbe
ship was hit by mines half of the people
on board died there now remember the
rebbe is in his stateroom he's down in
the middle of the ship and he's in a
wheelchair
they got hit by a torpedo just imagine
the chaos of trying to get him up to
lifeboat in his wheelchair but luckily
they made it through this one minefield
and he made it onto America and on the
18th of March 1940 his ship docked in
New York City Harbor on the 19th of
March he stepped foot on the soil of the
United States and he declared America to
be the new headquarters of yiddish kite
in the world of judaism in the world
there's a picture of the ship it was 600
feet long and it provided an easy target
for German u-boats had it been
misidentified or had it failed to help
to when a German
you boat called it to do so on the
drawing home was under the flag of
Sweden now telling you all this I've
only been able to scratch the surface of
all the different ways that the Rebbe
was saved and the different things that
had to take place and hopefully I've
sparked your curiosity to open up the
book and read it now I can give you
sixty reasons why the Rebbe should have
died I can't give you one a ye survived
as director Strauss rightly noted the
lab occurs say it was God it was the
divine intervention that saved the Rebbe
well as a secular historian that forces
me to ask where was God was six million
more people that needed to be rescued in
1939 now when the Rebbe got to America
he started to do an awful lot to rescue
his followers and family members over in
Europe and unfortunately most of his
efforts were failures
most of the as I just described with the
visa machinery in America was very
difficult to get a visa and as Professor
Henry Feingold wrote that once you
finally got the visa most often and
applied to a corpse and so the Rebbe had
a lot of frustration in this area I had
a lot of failures but he was successful
in getting one person out of Vichy for
our two people actually out of EC
friends that were incredibly important
for the movement and that was his
daughter and his son-in-law Menachem
Mendel Schneerson he would eventually
become the seventh Lubavitch Rebbe of
the kabab movement now if you don't have
the rescue of the six lubavitcher rebbe
joseph s auctioneers in in 1940 out of
europe you don't have the rescue of the
seventh lubavitcher rebbe menachem
mendel schneerson in 1941 out of Vichy
France if that happened you would have a
dramatically different kebab movement
today and dramatically weaker and
smaller
now when the Rebbe was having all these
difficulties he started to really focus
on his in his spiritual mission and a
lot of people have asked at this time
why didn't the Rebbe approach the
politicians that helped him to rescue
other lives if he was having so many
problems well this is the controversial
thing about this research he did
these politicians that had helped rescue
him but he didn't contact him the rescue
lives he contacted them to rescue his
library his forty thousand volume book
library and in nineteen forty one you
have several tons of books that show up
in two large semis at Brooklyn 772
headquarters now you can look at this in
two ways you can look at it one way why
was the Rebbe so obsessed with books as
directors ooh off of the V centella
Center in Israel has noted and I as well
now he should've been focusing on saving
lives and doing everything you could to
put his energies and resources into that
platform yet you can look at another way
in nineteen forty one you could get
several tons of books out of Europe but
you couldn't get one human soul also
this time many people have asked well
why didn't the Rebbe work with other
Jewish organizations the you know get a
unified front and help rescue lives well
this is a sad chapter of American Jewish
history at this time a lot of the
different organizations were fighting
amongst themselves and Rebbe Schneerson
he was very strong with his criticism of
especially the vaad hatzala the Jewish
Orthodox of the yeshiva world or
Orthodox rescue organization and the two
men that he took the tasks were rabbi
Aaron Cutler and Rabbi Avraham come on
Ovitz and he thought that these men were
unnecessarily compromising their
religious integrity by meeting with
secular leaders Christian leaders
meeting on the Sabbath organizing
protest marches petitioning the
government and he was calling this and
one instance Jewish Nazism he thought it
was really degrading the spiritual
essence of Judaism and it was causing
the Holocaust yet we see with what rabbi
cutler and Rabbi Commandments were doing
they were meeting with politicians they
were petitioning politicians they had a
huge protest march in nineteen forty
three and they were working with
secretary of the treasury Morgenthau and
they eventually brought about the war
refugee board in 1944 which saved
between 100 to 200 thousand lives and so
we see that the Rebbe you know made some
mistakes he missed opportunities and
this reminds me of the following story
there's a man by the name of John and he
lived on a hillside and
North Carolina with his family and all
Sun a huge thunderstorm came and the
whole region started to flood so some of
his neighbors came up to him and said
John come with your wife your two kids
get in the car it's dangerous to stay
here and John said no I believe in God I
have faith in God God will save me and
my wife and two children and also in the
waters rise up and John has to get his
family up on the roof and some other
neighbors come by in a boat and say John
get in the boat it's dangerous to stay
here it's flooding and John says no my
family we believe in God we have faith
in God he will save us and the waters
rise up and John has to get on the
chimney with his family and a helicopter
comes by he says here grab this rope
ladder ladder it's dangerous to stay
here and John yells out no I believe in
God God will rescue us save us how
awesome the waters rise up they sweep
John and his family away and they kill
in the waters kill him and when he gets
up to heaven he says God I believe in
you we believe in you look at my wife
and my children
why didn't you save us and God said what
are you talking about I sent you a truck
I sent you a bus and I sent you a
helicopter and I think this is the sad
story about my my book that it really
illustrates that so many opportunities
were missed in a lot of different
communities were fighting amongst
themselves you had the anti-zionist
finding the zionists the reformed
fighting the Orthodox you had the global
church fighting the yeshiva world
instead of uniting together and help
rescue lives this is one thing I try to
really get across in my book is that why
can't we see the beautiful bridges that
bond us instead of the tiny little
streams that divide us
now when the Rebbe had all these
failures he started to turn into his
inward and really look at his spiritual
mission and he believed that and the
reason why the Jews were having so many
problems under Hitler the reason why the
Holocaust was happening is because God
was displeased and he was punishing the
Jews for their sins he believed that
Jews were being punished for not keeping
the Sabbath holy not practicing the
family purity laws not praying not
studying Torah not doing their best to
keep the 613 commandments here are some
phrases that he gave he believed that
what was happening in Europe was an
edict from heaven issued to force all
Jews to
Shuba are to repentance who had left
Judaism as the Rebbe to find Judaism he
believed that the focus was wrong in the
secular world it should be focused on
God because only God could truly change
the situation
he said we mortals we Jews will not be
helped by politicians or governments the
wise and understanding person will not
be influenced by such foolishness we
Jews will be helped by Torah the
commandments and repentance
now here's an irony of history the Rebbe
is saying that secular and reformed Jews
were the cause of the Holocaust yet when
you look at Louis just justice Louis
Brandeis an assistant attorney Benjamin
Cohen our Ernst Blanc and two other men
that were in his unit that were of
Jewish descent he was rescued by those
very people yet this irony did not seem
to dawn on him a lot of rabbis and the
lebarge movement say that what the Rebbe
was saying is grounded in the Torah it's
grounded in biblical text as it says
here in Leviticus you know God says if
you do not maintain my covenant I will
give you over to your enemies yet one
can make an argument that is how you
interpret the Torah let's not forget
that Moses was punished by God for
slandering issue Israel and hitting the
rock and that's what it seems what what
the Rebbe was doing at this time he was
slandering Israel and also who do you
believe who comes on the scene and
begins speaking on behalf of God do you
believe Reverend Jerry Falwell who after
9/11 comes on the scene and says God is
punishing us with terrorism because of
pagans ie Jews Mormons Hindus then he
goes on and says feminists abortion
abortionist and homosexuals and he uses
the New Testament is a supporting
document
do you believe Osama bin Laden who comes
forward and says that the West is being
punished because Allah is displeased
with us and he uses the Quran or when
you're looking at the Holocaust do you
believe what the Satmar Rebbe Rabbi
Teitelbaum said that the Holocaust was
happening because of the Zionists God
was angry at the Zionists and here's
another irony Rebbe Teitelbaum
was rescued by the Zionists in 1944 from
nazi-occupied Europe describing this to
Chancellor Norman lamb of yeshiva
university he said what the Rebbe was
doing was blasphemy and he cites numbers
saying you know let's not forget Moses
was punished for also doing this and he
also cites the Midrash saying God does
not approve a one who slanders Israel
and why there's some the reason why
there's so much I think controversy
about this especially in the La Batre
communities because they've been stamped
by Menachem Mendel Schneerson the
seventh Lubavitch Rebbe and he had a
dramatically different way of looking at
the Holocaust in the way that he looks
at the Holocaust seems to vindicate what
a dr. rabbi Norman lamb said Menachem
Mendel Schneerson said to say that God
was punishing the Jews but the Holocaust
is a desecration of God's name and I
think this is a very humane and tolerant
way of looking at the Holocaust and this
is the philosophy that has really
inundated abolish today most of them do
not know about the six Laboratories a
take on the Holocaust they do know about
Menachem Mendel Schneerson stake on it
and this is why it's caused a lot of
confusion the idea that God is
omnipotent and intimately involved in
human affairs is full of a lot of
problems and is difficult to believe for
a secular historian as Karen Armstrong
wrote she said if God is omnipotent he
could have prevented the Holocaust if he
could not have prevented it that he's
impotent and useless and if he could
have prevented it and chose not to then
he's a monster well we can even take
this a step further and ask if God
actually ordered it what does this tell
us about God I think this shows you that
nobody really has a corner on the market
of why God is doing what he is doing you
know who are you going to believe I'm
going to believe Rebbe title bound rabbi
schneerson Reverend Jerry Falwell I like
what a famous Hasidic rabbi here in New
York City his name is Casso Besser it's
a wonderful man and very tolerant man
very brilliant I actually have the first
ascitic rabbi ever could talk to about
German military strategy of world war
two and he knew more generals than I
at that time and still does he said you
know I'm not in heaven and I'm not a
prophet and I don't know why God did the
Holocaust but I do know one thing is
that it teaches me that I need to be a
better person each day of my life I also
like what rabbi harold kushner wrote i
have his quote up here and i'm
paraphrasing when he says you know the
concept that god gives us what we
deserve
that our misdeeds caused our misfortunes
is a nice and attractive solution to the
problem of evil but it has several
problems on many levels it forces people
to blame themselves it creates it
creates guilt where there is no guilt
it makes people hate God and even worse
it makes them hate themselves and more
importantly it doesn't even fit the
facts I mean one can ask what the
Holocaust if God was punishing the Jews
for their sins with the Holocaust then
what about the gypsies the homosexuals
and the Slavs
that were killed also in the Holocaust
yet this view of the Holocaust at the
Rebbe had forced him like nothing else
to build up his community and America
and this is on one side you know it was
an incredible feat that he was able to
do but another side this has also
created a lot of controversy because a
lot of people have questioned why was he
focusing on building new shiva's in
schools in America when he should have
been focusing on using those resources
to save lives but nonetheless he was
extremely successful and as many of you
know the largest Hasidic community in
the world today is the Lubavitcher
community and they do an awful lot of
good helping people in prison helping
people who are in need of food and
shelter they're doing a lot with the
tsunami relief effort and so they do an
incredible outreach program and so this
has been the legacy of lavalla in many
respects and they have done amazing good
and without that rescue you would not
have had this community building itself
up the way that it has several people
have asked me what happened to block and
Canaris block after he rescued the
labonza revi went back to his duties in
the Secret Service and there's even some
evidence that I found that four months
later he rescued the gear
rebby which is the largest Hasidic
community in Israel and got him to Italy
where I was able to get on to Palestine
which is also an interesting story so it
seemed like he did some more rescue
efforts but then by 1943 a lot of his
activities in the Secret Service had
dried up and he was sent to the wet of
the Eastern Front as a regimental combat
commander he served one year there and
then after the July 1944 bomb attack on
Hitler Hitler started to revoke most of
the Aryan ization 's that he had given
to date and Bloch was discharged and
before he was sent to a forced labor
camp he was redrafted into a
paramilitary organization and he helped
trained soldiers to fight the Russians
and after he trained them he was sent up
to Berlin to fight the Soviets in one
week before the war ended he died in
battle
Canaris during the 1930s I was doing an
awful lot to get Hitler removed from
power
he believed especially by the early
1940s that Hitler was a disaster
in 1943 this these activities this
information got to the SS and Canaris
was arrested 1944 canaras was sent to a
concentration camp flossenbürg where he
was beaten up horribly and Terra gated
and his nose was cut off and one month
before the war ended he was hanged and
then put on a pile of wood and
incinerated I talked to a man recently
that actually watched this happen and he
says through his cell window he could
see the flakes of skin floating up in
the flames as he was burning so that's
what happened to these two men and
here's another scene take on the way
that Lubavitch deals with the history
many of them believe that it was God's
intervention that these men were angels
in human form as a result there's been
no effort by LaBonge to contact these
individuals and thank them and so on
because the spiritual world takes
president over everything else and you
know many of them believe that they're
living in the end times the time of the
Messiah so this emphasis sometimes is
understandable but it's also sad that
there's really been no focus on these
men who actually if you look at the
Americans and the Germans it was the
Germans that had a little motivation of
humanity the Americans the only reason
why they acted was because they were
politically pushed
they only acted the rest of the rebbe
because it was politically advantageous
to them the Germans here can Ericsson
have to act on this he could have gotten
that request and said okay I'm sending
20 on my agents up there
two weeks later reported after having
done nothing but he could have said hey
I sent them all up half of them are dead
I'm sorry you know there's nothing more
I can do for you and leave it at that he
put his life and the life of his men on
the line to help rescue rabbi Schneerson
and Jewish philosophy it says if you
save a life you save the world
well the rescue of the Rebbe saved
almost two dozen lives and all it took
was a little letter-writing a few
thousand dollars and the courage to
speak up in a sense it is sad that in
1939 the six million Jews who would die
in the Holocaust were not already z'
hopefully the story of the rescue of the
Reich rescue of the Rebbe and also just
the study of the Holocaust in general
will help help motivate all of us to
recognize the signs of genocide on the
horizon and stamp it out where we see it
unfortunately with the example of Rwanda
in the 1990s were 1.5 million Africans
were slaughtered and the current
genocide going on in Sudan shows us that
we're not doing enough all those of us
who hold up that banner never again we
have so much more to do and also looking
at the moral issues and questions of
history one just has to ask that if
there's 1.5 million Africans who were
slaughtered in Rwanda where 1.5 million
Americans are 1.5 million Jews how
different the response would have been
coming out of America yet were those
souls any different ultimately I believe
that the story of the rescue of the
Rebbe should force each one of us to
analyze our lives and see what we were
doing to help our fellow man especially
when that fellow man is in danger of
dying what are you doing to help mankind
the rescuers of Rebbe Schneerson felt
that by saving him they were saving the
greatest Jewish stage of their day and
even the potential Messiah by saving him
they were committing the ultimate act of
goodness so with this in mind what are
you giving of your time energy and
resources to make this world a better
place and if you're making contributions
how can you make those contributions
more effective and powerful the
followers of the Rebbe you know they
show us that uncommon people from
diverse backgrounds were able to unite
together and push through a positive
action to save lives
if ultra Hasidic Lubavitch or Jews can
work with an anti-semitic anti-refugee
US government that interns work with the
Nazi Secret Service to rest
one of the most prominent Orthodox
rabbis of 1939 then the question that
should be asked of us is what can we not
do if we decide to put away our petty
prejudices and our religious differences
to unite together and make this world a
better place the story ladies and
gentlemen shows us that each one of us
has an incredible opportunity every day
of our lives to make a difference
especially a difference in people's
lives who are in danger of dying all it
takes is the courage to speak up and the
willingness to put our time energy and
resources into a cause that is bigger
and better than ourselves recently
during a Shabbat service I heard the
following give out a phrase was given
out that really I think touches on this
it says pray as if everything depended
on God act as if everything depended on
you thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen
yes ma'am
yeah - uh yeah ready got rabbi Besser
Fred good to see you - ah I'll repeat
the question
I can't help it I've tried to be sold
with it
why did not my father was such a
righteous Dalek deserve to be fought for
his life my brothers my sisters and
every time I come upon a story like that
I feel like pulling my hair I feel my
fate is crashing I think men talk about
themselves to be God they had the power
as if they were God who should live and
who should die and you just you just
suffocate it so many questions which
there are no answers you only remain
more angry more frustrated more question
what does it say about God hmm now the
question you know what is this a whole
research you know say about about God I
think this is you know we're may be
blessed with 70 whoops okay
we're may be blessed with 70 or 80 years
of life I think the greatest danger from
what I've been able to see with my short
lifespan is when somebody comes forward
and says with my life of 50 or 60 years
this body of knowledge that I have is
the correct way and if you don't believe
the way that I do if you're not in this
circle then you're wrong and this leads
to incredible atrocities and I think
also misconceptions of history and I
like to give a little on that
that point one thing that we see with
Christianity during world war two
especially in Nazi Germany we see a huge
failure here and I think partly the
reason for that is the following
90% of the German population were
churchgoing members and many of them
were taught that this is the way that
you need to believe you may need to
believe in Jesus the Messiah he came for
your sins you believe in him you go to
heaven if you don't you're going to go
to hell and this way of thinking about
people are saved and not saved I think
it's very dangerous because a lot of
Christians when they view people as
saved and unsaved they view is those
people who are lost as inferior you know
why can't they just believe in Jesus
they believe in Jesus everything would
be ok they wouldn't have the Holocaust
you know they would have all the
problems in life never mind the fact
that the church has been usually the
cause of the problems the last two
thousand years they say you know those
Buddhists they're going to hell those
those Hindus they're going to hell why
can't they believe and they spiritually
exterminate these people and as we see
it not to Germany the the line between
thinking about people in those
categories and then stepping over it and
giving them a helpful push is very small
we see that the churches in Nazi Germany
were very many of them were very you
know willing to use God's name to
vindicate a lot of things that were
going on and I think this is something
that I try to bring out in the book in
all different areas is that anybody
comes forward and says my theology my
religion is the best way and I know why
God is doing what he is doing and here
are my religious texts danger especially
when you start pointing the finger and
condemning others yes thank you I didn't
stand you didn't explain why why was the
rebel against devadutt Sola and also
this block yeah family did you speak to
the fact yeah good question the question
is why was the Rebbe against the vaad
hatzala well the vaad hatzala was the
yeshiva world rescue organization they
call them lot of times than this nodding
and I think the reason why there was a
lot of bad blood between these two
organizations it goes back to the Vilna
Gaon you know who was against the
Hasidic movement these civic movement
the miss Namie Amuro always against one
another and the Rebbe really believed
that only God could change the situation
and he felt that rabbi Kotler rabbi come
out of us by their actions we're showing
that they didn't believe in God they
were trying to work I mean let me they
didn't believe in God to take care of
the whole situation that they were
believing that hey secular means and
political means were the way to do it
and they were violating their religious
integrity their spiritual integrity by
meeting on the Sabbath meeting with
secular leaders and doing these type of
things I think this is one thing that he
saw that was really horrible the next
question is about blocks children have I
interviewed them yes and they're
wonderful individuals one is a Buddhist
priest out in California another is a
doctor in Hamburg wonderful woman
another it was a retired civil servant
from Germany and then another one is a
engineer in Paris and these people it
was really beautiful for me especially
for the the two daughters the doctor up
in Hamburg I came to her house to
interview her and she was born I think
three months before her father died so
she never got to know her father and I
came there with probably about 300 pages
of documents and I sat her down I gave
these documents and she just started
crying and she said you've given me my
father she never knew anything about him
and many of the family according to the
Buddhist priests they said you know we
thought we thought of him as that Nazi
soldier that left us alone they never
understood this Prussian you know desire
to be loyal to your country and do your
duty but now that he's not the Nazi but
yet he was doing rescue mission that he
wasn't you know this one side of what
they were with this one character that
they were thinking that he was and in
this thing that they were scared that he
was suddenly they realized hey he did
some good you know it's not all black
and white and that's been a really great
you know blessing in my life so there
I've been touched with the whole family
and they're wonderful
I would like you to I would like you to
elaborate a van point namely is it true
that you happy had a choice either to
rescue his forty thousand volumes or a
number of Jewish people the question is
wasn't an option given to him either I
rescue the books or rescue people what
I'm talking about I don't think that was
as black and white as you're presenting
it I think what it is is is he was
taking resources away from rescue
activities and he was focusing on
rescuing the books at that time when
according to you know directors do
office wells myself he could have taken
those resources and focused on rescue
mission meeting politicians using all
those resources and that's where the
problem comes you know to the forefront
so in a sense yes he did have options
out there and you know in retrospect we
see that you know a lot of the decisions
that he made were mistakes he missed out
on opportunities yes Milton yes please
sure and this and this
this gentleman milton kramer he is the
son of hime kramer who's the brother of
samuel kramer and these two men here in
my book these are Zod Hakeem you know
these are righteous individuals the
Kramer family is incredible with hardly
any experience with you know doing these
rescue efforts they were able to get to
the very top of the US government and
get it to move to rescue 20 lives and if
we had had you know five thousand two
thousand one hundred Kramer's back then
we would have thousands of thousands of
more people today so this family is
incredible and this is the son
to shed a little light and to clarify
the point that this gentleman raised in
your response could you go into a little
bit more detail about the difference as
far as the legal difference between
rescuing books and rescuing people yes
they are not the same yeah no no Cramer
is very please please make a strong
point about sure if yeah very very good
point mill Cramer I mean if the Rebbe it
had been presented with those options
books or people its huh Locke ha that
you save lives period yeah I mean that's
that's clear but what the Rebbe was
doing at this time he was the focus and
I guess perspectives that was going on
at that time that you know he should
have been many people feel that he
should have been much more aggressive
and much more urgent a sense of urgency
in his actions which really wasn't there
and you know the album efforts that were
done to save him were not utilized to
save others he did have people that
eventually got to Eleanor Roosevelt but
when they met with Eleanor Roosevelt it
wasn't to rescue people under Nazi
Germany it was a rescue people and under
Stalin because that's where a lot of his
followers were so this is where the
confusion comes in but it had the Rebbe
been presented with you know books or
people how a car would have dictated and
his personality which acade he would
have rescued lives yeah that's very good
point huh
yeah yeah okay please no a comment and a
question first of all I appreciate your
message at the end of the presentation
about where we take this in terms of
what's going on in the world and thank
you your friends um my question is how
how is your book been received by Allah
Bubba ch mmm I love atures yeah very
good question thank you for that comment
one thing I want to throw out there with
the way that I ended one organization of
many of you are asking hey what can I do
Doctors Without Borders is an incredible
credible organization and a lesser-known
one is architects Without Borders you
can google it and find these websites
they go out and they help people who
don't have any resources to get medical
care or get homes now to your point
about the book how is the Babak received
it you know I was one time I was having
dinner with several about your rabbis
and you know me being the person I am
and how I was trained I was sitting
around the table and I said you know I
think the Rebbe only made three mistakes
dead silence and then I realized well I
guess I shouldn't talk about the French
prostitute yeah that's a joke you know
and you know and when and when I said
that to them there was also just a
deeper silence yeah so you know it's
it's very hard to deal with these people
when they don't realize this guy he had
you know body order mistakes he fell
down you know he bled he had feelings he
had emotions he had lust you know he was
a human being and so when I started
coming out and saying hey you know he
missed the boat a few places here or
he's you know why is he condemning these
people instead of just you know working
on himself they have a very hard time
with this I'll give you a few examples
of some of the experiences I had one
husted one the boxer hosted wonderful
man of course I'm not going to be able
to name some of these individuals I mean
he's a wonderful guy and he calls me up
he's like this is incredible you know I
never knew all this these are going on I
was like well thank you very much sir
you know since you are a revered person
in the community can I use you as a
blurb that would be wonderful he's like
you got to realize as a hostage yeah I
can't do that you know I can't come out
and or something that says something
like this about the Rebbe and also they
you know they have had a lot of problems
dealing with a lot of their history you
know here again Chabad is a wonderful
organization they do an awful lot of
good but they have a lot of hard times
coming to terms with their past
like for example Menachem Mendel
Schneerson he studied in Berlin never
got a degree in the Sorbonne or Berlin
no matter how much they tell you that he
was an engineer working for the Secret
Service with the Navy and so on but when
he got photographed for the Berlin
University he wasn't wearing a yarmulke
when that picture came to lahbab which
they painted a yarmulke on the picture I
had some lavalla sure rabbis from you
know chabad.org
get in touch with me and they said you
know I cuz I was giving it out to
everybody I couldn't get feedback you
know I am one person I'm a human being I
make mistakes you know help me out here
and that Milton Kramer was incredible I
own probably about 20 red pencil
he went through about five drafts in my
work he was a wonderful individual also
exotic in the Kramer fashion and so you
know this rabbi he got in touch with me
or I guess he's a Shiva student but he
had a lot of documents he read my
manuscript and he said hey I got a lot
of documents and I think you need to
change a lot of things in chapter 14
which is talking about the rabies view
of the Holocaust
he's like besides where did you get all
those sayings from the Rebbe what
sources are you using and I said I'm
using your sources Keyhoe table Shing
the Chabad publishing house he's like oh
but then he said hey I got all these
documents is going to change what you
think I was like okay great that's my
job as a historian he's like I'll tell
you what I'll give you two or three
documents at a time you incorporate it
into your book I'll see how you
incorporate it and then I'll reserve the
right to give you more documents I said
hey I can't do that that's unethical and
also I mean you can give me you know
five or six documents that shows that
Bush is an incredible public speaker but
if you give me the whole document trail
of a campaign we're gonna have a
different story you know so I got a look
I got a look at everything you know to
give me the context of the history I had
another rabbi from Lubavitch get in
touch with liens and you know from
Chabad org and say hey you know if you
take that out I can guarantee a
thousands of dollars and you'll be on
the Chabad lecture circuit yeah I was
like but they're gonna people want to
know what they did with it you know what
they did what he did with his rescue
soul Obama CH how they responded I think
many of them are fascinated by the story
they might read it in private but as far
as far as coming out and saying you know
this is you know incredible we endorsed
it they have a hard time it's like
asking a born-again Christian to look at
Jesus in human terms that he had lust in
his heart that he struggled with things
you know that he maybe kiss Mary Mary
Magdalene according to the Vinci Code
who knows you know so it's very hard to
take them from that spiritual world and
look at this in a very black-and-white
situation you know there's always three
sides every story his side her side and
the truth
this lady has been very patient well
thank you Frank it's not often you have
the director from the Judicial Center
here run around for you thank you for
anything sir
I figured that you gave on the number of
Jews serving in Hitler's army in
staggering if I remember correct you
said something like fifty thousand um
the the figure is sixty thousand half
Jews and ninety thousand quarter Jews
who served in the German armed forces so
150 thousand so-called Micheline
soldiers according to the Nazis my
question is it is but question my
comment is and I would like you to
comment on that it is seems
inconceivable that these people knowing
where they came from and knowing what
Hitler was about would willingly want to
fight in Hitler's lobby
very good question and that's a question
that plugged me for you know 12 years as
I did this research and wrote the book
and I would if you're really interested
in knowing the full details of that I
encourage you to look at my first book
Hitler's Jewish soldiers now the 100 the
quick answer that the 150,000 so-called
initialling soldiers is a very small
percentage of the valmont by 1945 over
18 million men went to the ranks of the
German armed forces so the so called
partial Jewish soldiers 150 thousand of
them represent less than 1% of the total
manpower of the German armed forces and
when you look at assimilation birth
rates the mixed marriage race and after
talking to a few statisticians that's
how I came to that number
now this is what's crazy half Jews and
quarter Jews had to serve they were
conscripted they didn't have a choice
you know what when a half G was
contribute he couldn't go to the draft
board and say you know I feel Jewish
you're perfect you're persecuting my
family I don't want to serve there was
no such thing as a conscientious
objector back then and you know Hitler
did not did not know the Pandora Box
that he was going to open up when he was
declaring that these men had to serve I
first of all I don't think he knew the
numbers that he was dealing with and
second of all I don't think he really
thought far enough ahead to really look
at the problems that he would create for
his regime cuz think about it these guys
are serving all sudden mom is being you
know beaten up in the street grandma's
being arrested and thrown in an SS
prison dad is losing his work and many
of these guys are going to their
superiors and saying hey look I served
this country honorably
I have the iron cross and look how my
family's being treated and many of these
requests eventually reached Hitler and
by 1940 he started to discharge the half
Jews from the military but this
discharge order was very hard to push
through because a lot of half Jews
didn't even know themselves that they
were have Jews many of them were
successful hiding their ancestry and
this discharge order wasn't being widely
enforced also Hitler had decreed in this
discharge order that any half Jew who
had performed well in battle was allowed
to apply for clemency and so he had
thousands of guys submitting
applications like Bloch did and Hitler
was actually giving thousands of you
know clemency documents to these people
so when you look at assimilation in
Germany you start realizing how the
German military was organized it's not
that shocking anymore that 150,000
people of Jewish descent served in the
military the tragedies are how these men
dealt with that what their experiences
were and on average every man who I
documented lost between 7 & 8 relatives
in the show up the Holocaust so this is
a new chapter I would say many respects
of the Holocaust that has been looked at
very closely and I was blessed to fall
into it and do 10 years or 12 years of
research culminated in these two books
thank you
talk about your research maybe can talk
about maybe some mysteries or things you
reveal that's gonna be your next book
mm-hmm Thank You Gayle for the question
I have a book that's coming out with
Yale University here in a year and it's
called voices of Hitler's Jewish
soldiers and I've taken 27 of the most
interesting case studies and I've
written up their biographies because a
lot of people have asked me the last two
years on the you know lecture circuit
you know how did this guy feel what did
he do you know there's some of these men
that they served in the military and
then later on they served in the Israeli
army and a lot of difficult issues that
are surrounding these guys that bring up
a lot of troubling questions about
identity and history like for example
one man that I have to note just to tell
you a little bit of a flavor what I'm
talking about
his name was heinrich meyer and he had
served two years in the van lock he was
discharged and then he was lucky to
remain in berlin for a few years before
he was sent to a forced labor camp he
survived that camp and after the war he
went down to israel
and he's certain Israeli military for
several years and the 1953 his company
commander calls him to the duty Hut and
says you know you need to go down to the
courthouse and get your ID papers in
order
Meyer goes down there and the bureaucrat
pulls out the file on him and says okay
Meyer you served a few years in the Vale
macht
how'd that happened Meyer explained okay
you were persecuted for being a Jew
under Nazi Germany you lost your father
in Auschwitz you were sent to a forced
labor camp what about your mother
uh well my mom she's a Gentile she's a
Christian Oh said the bureaucrat you're
not Jewish wait a second said Meyer I
was persecuted for 12 years under Hitler
for being a Jew lost my father in
Auschwitz I was sent to a forced labor
camp I've now served five years in the
Israeli military I've been wounded seven
times I'm an officer you're telling me
I'm not Jewish
hey he says I'm just telling you what's
on the book on the books you can either
prove that your mother is Jewish by
halaqa and the law of return or you can
convert to Judaism well I'm an atheist
Meyer said well we have a problem
said the bureaucrat Meyer got so fed up
with this that he returned to Germany's
and maybe in a democratic country I can
decide who I want to be so these type of
stories really putting the human face on
it is what I'm going to be diving into
with this next book and then I'm
actually working on a book about my
learning just a difficulties because if
I can you know go to Yale and Cambridge
with the way that I started out you know
anybody came with the right attitude and
motivation my mom a lot of people asked
her you know you must be so proud she
says well of course I am on the mom but
more than that I'm just relieved she
said she says I was expecting to see
pictures of him later yeah one more okay
one more question and the way back okay
okay can I enter that is hi um to be
honest tamil abhava church so hey
nobody's perfect
thank you it's a fascinating story that
you're telling about how the previously
Bob travel was saved from Europe I have
to admit I am slightly disturbed by the
conjecturing divergence about if or if
not did the free the crevasse save Jews
that he worked to save Jews was he able
to save Jews especially since I know my
wife's grandfather received a visa due
to the efforts of the previous
lubavitcher rebbe sure punished him and
eight friends went to Montreal yeah
through Shanghai yeah they were in the
wars were so ghetto hmm how can you say
with certainty what a person didn't do I
mean as a story and you look up the
trail what people did do mm-hmm
how can you tell what people didn't do
here especially since I'm aware of a lot
of people who were saved okay very good
question thank you um you know when you
look at what supposedly the Rebbe was
doing you would find corresponding
documents in the National Archives or
the presidential library and Hyde Park
with Roosevelt all you find there you
find a lot of documents from rabbi
Kotler and rabbi command of its
petitioning the government they're
asking the government to bomb the links
to Auschwitz they're doing everything
they can and they're trying to get other
people on board they're working with
reform rabbis they're working with
secular the Berks and boys and they're
doing an awful lot of good the Rebbe is
condemning them at this time instead of
working with them that's one proof right
there he missed an opportunity of
putting away religious differences the
yeshiva world could have done the same
thing there was bad blood on both sides
but instead of condemning then he should
have gonna say hey what can I do with my
hundred and sixty thousand followers in
Canada and America to help rescue lives
those documents aren't they're also the
what you could do more as far as
rescuing you know cult learned
Commandments are also
examples of what yiddish-speaking you
know Eastern European ultra-orthodox
Jews were able to do they were meeting
all over the place
petitioning people and here again this
is what I want to get across you know
with red you know why can't we just see
the common humanity we all share and
work together to help save lives instead
of pointing fingers and that was what
the Rebbe was doing a lot at that time
and if there was a lot of rescue efforts
that were done with the government the
documents aren't there now if you have
the documents I will be more than happy
to stand corrected but I haven't seen
him after ten years of research now the
one question that I wanted to I was
allowed to answer this gentleman in the
front said how did my family respond
when I came and found out about my
Jewish background and you know I and you
know how did they view themselves today
well when I came forward to a lot of my
family members they said you know I
wouldn't talk about this that much we
have enough problems as a family as it
is we don't need anti-semitism as well
and I said well you know you love Jesus
and he was a Jew ah that's different
they said I was like no it's not he was
a rabbi uh ventually many of them have
come around a few uh one of my cousin's
came forward and said hey you know what
Bryan's found out I always suspected I
had some of these historical leads and
he's a lot older cousin he's in his 60s
now wonderful mind and so a lot of
people came forward and start looking at
it my mom actually now embraces it she
goes to a messianic synagogue every now
and then this is the Jews for Jesus
organization when the Orthodox rabbi who
had helped me learn about my you know
Yukos
you know my Yiddish guide my Jewish
background when he heard about this he's
like oh they that's worse yeah he's like
that's 20 step backwards so you know
they've embraced it and you know the way
that it's kind of focused you know me
and you know I was brought up in a very
Christian environment when I was 8 years
old
I was told in the Bob the Bible Church I
was at you got to ask Jesus into your
heart when you ask Jesus into your heart
that's when you go to will be able to go
to heaven live for eternity with God and
all your family members no pain is
wonderful if you don't do this you're
going to go down to hell and live with
Lucifer and fry for all eternity there's
going to be you know pools of human
flesh reaching up and grabbing you
blood the gnashing of teeth and we're so
for an eight-year-old this decision was
a no-brainer I asked Jesus into my heart
I got my fire insurance so you know then
I hit around 12 or 13 and I go to a
Church of Christ school and they have a
different doctor in a different theology
and I've had a Bible School a Bible
class at this school and after the class
you talked about salvation and I told
him about what had happened to me he's
like no no no no you got it all wrong
it's not that christening you had in the
Presbyterian Church when you were kids
sprinkled it's not that baptism you did
after you ask Jesus into your heart in
the Bible Church you have to actually be
baptized the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Ghost and only then when
you come out of the water
do you have salvation all sudden I
started feeling the flames underneath my
feet I was like oh no I did it all wrong
and so I asked the teacher could you
take me up to the baptism in the church
on the hill by the church and baptize me
he's like sure and I was just hoping God
wouldn't hit me with a lightning bolt
that I took from you know going from the
school to the church took about 20 50
yards but I got up there without getting
hit I get baptized and when I come out
the pearly gates are open to me I got my
salvation but then I get a little bit
older and I'm sorry to get disturbed by
a lot of things that I'm hearing from a
lot of Christians this condemnation of
you know we're saved and you're not you
know those people are going to hell and
there's a lot of intolerance there and
they treat people as inferiors in many
respects and they don't live the
religion they only act at it they are in
the religion for what it does for
themselves they're not really in there I
mean did you see Jesus wearing Rolexes
driving Mercedes you know not in
especially in Texas you have segregated
churches you know a lot of people I even
had people tell me when I was young you
know negative things about Jews and
blacks in the church is that in the
spirit of Jesus who actually probably
looked more black than he did as the
pictures we see blonde and blue-eyed and
so I started seeing a lot of hypocrisy
here so I started going on my own Jewish
on my own spiritual journey and then I
find out about my own Jewish background
when I'm 21 and then I get a scholarship
to go to ultra Orthodox Jew Sheva over
in Jerusalem and I'm over there with the
yeshiva buckos and you know I'm learning
about my Yiddish guide my Jewishness I'm
embracing it I'm very excited about
learning about these things but I'm also
hearing some disturbing things I'm
hearing you know those Co frame Jews
those reforms you secretaries those are
the reasons why we are those people the
reasons why we have problems here on
earth they're the reason why we had the
Holocaust they're the reason why we
don't have the Messiah and at that stage
you know we ask me where am I am right
now with my Jewish journey I believe you
know maybe God gave us religion but
Satan organized it and that's kind of
where I'm at right now
I know I know that I don't know I'm 33
and the older I get the Dumber I realize
I am and you know I'm very intolerant of
intolerance and I'm doing the best with
what I have
so that's fine thank you very much
brien mark rig teaches history at
American military University and
Southern Methodist University he's the
author of Hitler's Jewish soldiers his
latest rescued from the Reich is
published by Yale University Press